Es ist Sommer, die Leute sind gut drauf,
reden wir also über den Tod!
Die Moderne stellt einen vor viele Herausforderungen,
logische Folge:
Überforderung, Verzweiflung und Ängste.
Und damit nicht genug: Viele sind gerade auch
in ihrer Angst überfordert:
Vor wem soll ich denn jetzt Angst haben?
Vorm Russen, vorm Terroristen oder vorm Wolf?
Viele Menschen entscheiden sich dafür, Angst
vor Terror zu haben.
Es hilft, einen Blick in Mordstatistiken zu
werfen, um herauszufinden, von wem die eigentliche
Gefahr ausgeht: Die meisten Menschen werden
ja gar nicht von Terroristen ermordet,
sondern von ihren eigenen Bekannten.
Das ist die gute Nachricht!
Die allerwenigsten Menschen werden überhaupt
umgebracht, aber wenn man umgebracht wurde,
dann kannte man den Mörder meistens schon.
Fast ein Drittel aller Morde sind Beziehungstaten.
Falls Sie sich das gerade als heterosexuelles
Paar angucken und nervös werden,
kleiner Tipp:
Wahrscheinlich ist der Mann der Täter.
Der Aufklärer sagt: Habt keine Angst vor
Fremden,
habt lieber Angst vor eurer eigenen Familie!
Vor einigen Jahren gab es eine spannende Meldung
aus den USA.
Da hieß es dann, dass in den Jahren zuvor
mehr Menschen durch herabfallende Fernseher
umgekommen waren, als durch Terroristen.
Ich glaube ja mittlerweile, es ist völlig
egal, welche Sterbeart man sich ausdenkt,
es macht auf jeden Fall jedes Jahr ein Amerikaner
mit.
Als ich das mit den herabfallenden Fernsehern
gehört habe,
haben sich mir sofort drei Fragen aufgedrängt:
1.
Wer ist der Anführer der Fernseher?
2.
Kann man ihn töten?
3.
Und was ist eigentlich die Rolle der Geheimdienste?
Fast 10.000 Menschen sind 2015 in Deutschland
bei Unfällen im Haushalt gestorben,
80 % davon durch:
Hinfallen.
Wie spektakulär ist das?
Auf ein Mordopfer kommen in Deutschland zwanzig
Leute, die sich sagen: ich lass mich nicht
umbringen, ich fall einfach so in meiner Wohnung
um und DANN bin ich tot.
Teppiche und Staubsaugerkabel haben mehr kriminelle
Energie, als man ihnen zutraut.
Man muss keine Angst haben, rauszugehen.
Man muss Angst davor haben, drinnen zu bleiben!
Gut, beim Rausgehen kann man zum Beispiel
überfahren werden.
Einigen wir uns auf den Kompromiss: Aktivität
ist einfach immer gefährlich!
Islamistischer Terrorismus ist nicht lustig.
Er sollte mit allen demokratischen Mitteln
des Rechtsstaats bekämpft werden.
Aber warum macht niemand was gegen Treppen?
Während in Deutschland in den letzten 10
Jahren 16 Menschen durch islamistischen Terror
umgekommen sind, sind im gleichen Zeitraum
über 10.000 Menschen
beim Treppensteigen gestorben.
Das war grad übrigens der Treppenwitz dieser
Geschichte …
Während jährlich über 1000 Menschen von
Treppen ermordet werden, bringen Aufzüge
im Jahr keine 10 Menschen um.
Und wovor haben Menschen Angst?
Vor Aufzügen.
Die Indizien mehren sich langsam, dass Angst
nichts Rationales ist.
Die Leiter, eine besonders hinterhältige
Form der Treppe,
bringt jährlich über 100 Leuten den Tod!
Wir brauchen nicht strengere Anti-Terror-Maßnahmen,
sondern strengere Anti-Leiter-Maßnahmen.
Und ich glaube, der strategische Fehler liegt
darin, an den Flughäfen alle Leitern unkontrolliert
ins Land einreisen zu lassen.
Sogar Babys sind in den USA übrigens gefährlicher
als Terroristen.
2015 sind dreißig Amerikaner von Kleinkindern unter sechs Jahren erschossen worden.
Klar, wenn so viele geladene Waffen rumliegen,
ist es nur eine Frage der Zeit,
bis irgendwann mal ein Kleinkind gegen den Abzug krabbelt.
Und auch hier sagt der Aufklärer wieder:
Habt keine Angst vor Fremden –
habt lieber Angst vor eurer eigenen Familie,
im Zweifelsfall ist es das Baby!